and what's a rod yes welcome to to my
home we've gone full circle you call in
I come to see you and now you're with me
in the studio thank you sir it's lovely
my first time here yes it's so iconic to
see all this stuff so I watch Sky every
day I know I know you watch at home so
thank you for coming in I mean you pick
your moments don't you and when you
first spoke to us on Sky News it was
about the NHS crisis and you've come in
today to a government again in crisis
you've seen the news about Boris Johnson
a committee of MPS finding that he lied
to Parliament essentially he's a
disgraced ex-prime Minister now
you make of it all well you know I was
and still I am a bit of a fan of Boris
because I think he's got wonderful
Charisma but you know you knew what you
were getting with Boris you know so it's
It's Not Unusual he's told a few Paul
his over the years so I'm I'm not
surprised he's in big trouble now but
how is he going to make a comeback I
don't know maybe you should talk to me
I've been making comebacks for years
well there you go maybe that's a
collaboration but essentially MPS are
trying to ban him from Westminster from
politics there might not be a comeback
in terms of
how the government's sitting at the
moment I know when we last spoke when he
called into Sky News you said it was
time for a change of government
absolutely the case Dharma has called
for a general election where do you sit
when it comes to that
obviously they're not going to allow a
general election because they're in such
a bad place this is like you know being
the bottom of the league they couldn't
they can't get any worse with the
tourists so but they won't call the
elections no doubt about it is that
quite depressing to be sitting at home
watching in terms of obviously you said
you're a fan of Boris because of his
personality or when you think about you
know what's happening in the state of
politics how it's affecting people's
lives right now cost of living crisis
the NHS I could go on is it quite a
depressing statement it is yeah I mean
I've got people that work for me and
they're struggling you know I'm just
giving a 10 rise I gave him a rise two
years ago because they're struggling the
cost of living is ridiculous and where's
it going to go yeah what's going to
happen who's going to sort this out yeah
who is going to sort yeah that's a big
question you're lucky you're an employee
that could afford to do that not
everyone can yeah it's a final question
about what's been going on today before
we talk about you
um
part of this route is about
um the honors list the resignation
honors list that Boris Johnson put in
before he left office and there's been
causing the House of Commons today for
that to be scrapped and obviously you
sit here as Sir Rod Stewart you know
it's a different kind of Honor but just
in terms of rewards they're given out
knighthoods peerages
do you feel there should be a clearer
system in terms of you know you were
awarded for your contribution to music
and your charity work but you know
people watching Sky News will be
thinking hang on a second you've got
personal assistance being you know put
forward for peerages does all of that
need to change yeah it does think of a
bit of you scratch mine back and I'll
scratch yours I don't know the details
of it but I know some of the people that
he chose it was a bit of you know he's
my mate type of thing yeah it should be
sorted out because the the honors are
wonderful absolutely one of the proudest
day of my life where I became a
Knighthood and I think from that day on
people have asked me you're doing a lot
of charitable stuff and I think yes
because I'm a knight I don't want to be
seen as doing good I think I told you
this before yeah and would you get my
jacket and shirt I love it well I I
heard your jacket coming before I heard
you it's so impressive don't often like
to be upstaged on the style front of my
show but I'll let I'll let you officer
Rod you're a friend of the show you're
on the inside now I've got you in my
studio and when we first spoke it was
during our NHS phone in and you were
watching at home and you wanted to help
and you called in you offered
um free scans at your local hospital
which was arranged I came to see that it
was incredible the people you were
helping that day and you spent a lot of
time with them talking to them about you
know what a difference this was making
um to their treatment where are you now
with that because you you did say on
that day that you know you wanted to
continue this so this was a long-term
commitment for you it wasn't just a
publicity stunt no certainly not well we
haven't got very far unfortunately Sarah
I thought it would have been a lot of
people calling me up um uh we just did
one at Harlow yeah and I've got another
one I think somewhere near Glasgow
coming up but I really need everybody to
help me out here you know to I want to
pay for scans so just get in touch
oh
I'll be the go between I'm more than
happy to why do you think you think that
is because
we're in the middle of a junior doctor
strike we know the NHS is struggling we
spoke five months ago about this and you
know it was going on a long time before
that why are you finding it so difficult
to
to give help I think because it's so
involved and there's so many you know so
many people in between me and whoever is
is can organize it for me bureaucratic
yeah exactly that's a great word you use
there Sarah
yeah
lots of red tape lots of lots of paper
and lots of people involved is
essentially what that means um so you're
appealing for people if they're in a
position to help to make it easier for
you because you're ready to go on this
right yeah absolutely absolutely
um and in terms of the junior doctor
strike like I said we're right in the
middle of another one a 72-hour strike
that's taking place as we sit here now
do you still support them that the
Public's still with them do you feel do
you feel like you know of course I do
I'm I'm A working class guy you know
I've made my facts wrong but apparently
they haven't had a rise for 12 years or
something you know and this is just to
get them even yeah you know it's uh
where's all the money gone yeah I know I
pray millions in taxes so where's it all
gone yeah that's a good point actually
because you know the government does say
that there's all this um talk about
um non-don status and taxing the rich
and the top percent of the millionaires
but you know I guess you would counter
that in terms of you're a wealthy man
and you you know you don't hide that and
like you said you pay a large amount to
the tax man yeah and you don't feel like
you're seeing the results and yet they
talk about taxing you more yeah but
there's tax in the rich it didn't it
didn't work with Harold Wilson back in
1974 I think because there was a what
they called a brain drain in those days
everybody left all the musicians left I
was on a plane with Joe Cocker Eric
Clapton the Bee Gees and we all left on
the 4th of April before the new tax year
it doesn't work you know there's got to
be another way but in saying that don't
forget we've got a war in Ukraine which
is costing us and of course brexit costs
us a lot of money yeah being pinched on
all sides of course brexit affecting
your industry in terms of music and how
musicians can tour and travel have you
have you found that I mean obviously the
tour that's coming up is a UK tour but I
know you go to the states is that
something that's you've had to factor in
when you think about where you're going
to take your music next year will be
because we have to go we're going into
Europe playing all over Europe so that
it's going to be difficult to sort out
it's very difficult for small bands it
really is yeah and you mentioned Ukraine
um again being generous
he helped refugees in this country which
I know you you've spoken about talk to
me about how that came about what you
did and as we know you don't just like
to do something and walk away are you
still supporting them oh absolutely yeah
it's um we started out my two nephews
said we've got to do something about
this I'm cool so we're going to get
three vans drive all the way to Ukraine
drop off lots of supplies and it's well
documented and then it drove back and
picked up about 12 or 15 refugees
dropped them all in Berlin and came back
that was the first step so then we took
another step I rented a house whole
house for a whole family and they were
so appreciative such gorgeous people and
you know a couple of them worked for me
now housekeeper and a gardener yeah so
um just want us they want them to win I
want us to win yeah I mean we're
following it here on Sky News closely as
you know as you're an avid viewer how
many villagers have we got now yeah I
know to do what where's the Michael and
Sir Michael Clarke I'm knighted him he's
that good professor Michael Clarke when
you need him we'll get an update on that
a little bit later
um let's talk about your UK summer tour
it's kicking off at the end of this
month and and I read that it's you've
called it your last Rock And Roll tour
which sounds to me by the end of an era
well you could put it that way it's just
um you know I've been singing Hot Legs
and Maggie May for 50 odd years
yeah it's it's time for a change all
things must end and I just want to
become
I want to sing Jazz and that's a wide
field you know I did the American
Songbook which sold 27 million and I've
just done an album with George Holland
which is a swing album
so we're going to do that and when's
that coming out the collaboration
Mother's Day next year excellent good
timing
um so that's the kind of Direction
you're going in and you know does it
feel
a little bit sad because you know you
mentioned the song Maggie May and you
know whenever I tell people that I'm
speaking to you that is always a song
that comes up there are others obviously
but those songs have such a personal
resonance for people special moments in
their life special events are you
feeling quite sad to sort of retire that
from your touring portfolio and yeah a
little bit it's um
that's what songs are all about they
bring back memories for you they don't
see a Maggie made tonight's the night I
think more children were born or
conceived in 1976 when tonight's the
night came out than any other song but
songs are all about memories eventually
so but you know
especially then or something I'll I'll
sing them again but right now I just
want to do some jazz yeah no swing music
I hear you something a bit different and
like you said you it's something you've
done before very successfully so now you
want to concentrate on that and I was
reading an interview with Sir Paul
McCartney and he was talking about AI in
music and he was talking about the fact
that he might experiment with it to put
together a final Beatles song
essentially lifting John Lennon's voice
for an old demo tape and putting it into
new music where do you stand with that
kind of experimentation is that
something you'd like to look at or are
you with a band of artists who are
saying this is not good for for
individual creators yeah yeah I'm
assuming I haven't done too much reading
about it did know that Paul has has put
together a single it's scary I mean it
it could be this destruction of mankind
as we know it apparently so we have to
protect ourselves yeah as far as music
goes I don't really care no no one
sounds like me and just finally for you
there's plenty more on the horizon in
terms of you know albums a different a
new tour and obviously a different kind
of tour I would imagine when you decide
to go out again but as we talk about Sir
Elton your friend he's bringing down the
curtain on his touring at glasstow next
weekend at glasfree Festival which
you've played uh is his big farewell
show and he's done this farewell tour
and he's drawing the curtain do you have
any thoughts about ending touring
because I would imagine that's a big
decision you've been touring for decades
and seemed to be still really enjoying
it I do what what does what does the
next chapter look like for you the same
thing on a smaller scale the different
music I don't think Elton will just pack
in like that and he'll sing those songs
on a special occasion and so will I it's
just that month after month being on
tour that we're not going nothing to do
and and why is that is that just because
you know a change of Lifestyle for you
mentioned your children going to school
here is it just just something that's
right now I love the British I love
British I love Britain and I think this
was the same he has his children I've
got my children were happy and yeah we
want to be close to them because we're
not getting any younger
and of course your um your wife Penny
are you Facebook about extensively and
you know it is involved in the police
and I know she was policing the
coronation that's a that's a big part of
her identity now she's very proud to you
know represent the police in this
country and what are your thoughts on on
the state of the police now and again it
comes back to
well we look at what's been unfolding in
Nottingham and the police you know doing
their job in that and the the most
horrific of circumstances what are your
views on you know how the police are
treated in this country and scene
um yeah that's a hard one because
they're not doing their job but
apparently they're not yeah so um I
think we should be supportive of the
police and uh Penny loves it she adores
being a copper you know
yeah I bet she does and does she feel
the support of people when she's out and
about doing action she really does yeah
yeah she really does when she did the
coronation she was so proud there was a
picture of her in the papers looking
straight at beaming like this with the
coach going behind him yeah she adores
it and it's great for her to get out the
house and do it I push her to do it yeah
you know and you manage to make it work
with all your touring and all her units
as well it's really commendable and it's
supposed to do it pleasure as always
thank you so much thank you I'm a big
fan you know
it's